hello guys Perry back with another
Sundance interview in the collider
studio thanks to the Kia Telluride a
huge thanks to them for making this
happen because it means we can be here
with this great ensemble and a very
talented director to talk about the
movie loose so Julius I want to start
with you here because I know you've been
working on this for quite some time and
I know the idea was developed a while
back so what is it like bringing this
movie to audiences today after working
on it for so long it's really gratifying
first of all it's amazing to be able to
have such a talented and passionate
group of actors to work with and you
know the questions and the ideas that
the film is exploring are ones that you
know have always kind of been a part of
American culture and I think right now
we're in a pretty divisive moment so
there are even much more pressing of
questions and the kind of conversation
it's trying to stimulate are things that
I think are necessary and important can
you give a little breakdown of the story
for our viewers out there who do not
know what this movie is about absolutely
it's about an upper middle class white
couple played by Tim Roth and Naomi
Watts who adopt a young man from Eritrea
played by Calvin Harris and junior who
is a former child soldier and this kid
becomes a real icon and a real symbol in
his community of success but when he has
a teacher played by Octavia Spencer who
assigns a paper he writes one that
advocates political violence basically
saying it's okay to do some pretty
gnarly things and it you know affects
his relationship with a teacher with his
parents and kind of has a huge impact on
his immediate community Calvin can you
tell me a little bit about the
conversations you two had when you first
signed on we're there every and were
there any specific questions you had for
Julius that you really needed answers I
had all the specific questions for
Julius III I guess I just there's a lot
of things that Luce does in the film
that I just had I was wondering why
because I'm just not a I'm not a fighter
per se that sounds bad but I always tell
people if I were to draw and I'll
probably just float and just close my
eyes and rest but Lewis is not that guy
he's gonna swim and so I think I just
was like why is he fighting so hard for
this and he kind of he kind of basically
told me I told him some stories about my
high school experience and growing up
and that's some of the racial race
issues I faced and he was
like they're very similar and it's not
that far from you so it was just trying
to to humanize the 17 year old boy who
is a human being that I just for some
reason put in a box too you know and I
was wondering if there's any difference
in terms of the different generations
represented in the movie specifically
for the adults and then these teenagers
so can you two speak a little bit to
that point well I think we grew up in a
generation where our parents set the
tone and said this is who you're going
to be this is the path that we want you
to go on and we kind of just accepted
that we're now in a new time where the
kids are saying you know what no we we
are actually smart people we can trust
ourselves we can shape our identities
and we don't need you interfering and I
think this is what this film is about it
happens with both Luce Kelvin and and
Stephanie's character Stephanie not yeah
and they're pushing back and saying
we're in charge of our identity and
please don't put your agenda onto us can
you tell us a little bit about your
character Oh feel free I love the
challenge of having so many people and I
want to get everybody a little bit of
time here can you tell me a little bit
about your characters relationship to
loose and how your experience throughout
the movie differs from his yeah I play I
guess I don't want to give away too much
but I play Lucis classmate and I
actually feel like my character
Stephanie is quite similar to loose out
of all the characters which is Stephanie
kind of has the ability to shed a
different light on Lucis character which
is super important to the movie and
Marsha where do you step in here I play
Octavia's sister Harriet sister Rosemary
and I think I'm there to sort of throw a
little monkey wrench into her somewhat
very steady life that she's established
for herself and so between Luce and I
I think we kind of just mess it up a
little bit can you talk a little bit
about working with a Octavia cuz she is
one of the people in this industry that
I admire greatly and I love seeing all
the different projects she chooses
because she chooses them with such value
and purpose so I just have a great
respect for her I I mean she's one of my
heroes obviously and I was really happy
the first day we worked together she we
were in the car and they had mentioned
something technical that I I didn't know
what it was but you know as a new person
on set you don't want to ask anyone who
seemed like you don't know and I
remember her turning to me and be like
I'm sorry she's she's so disused I have
no idea what this thing is they keep
mentioning it and I was like oh my god
me too and so I loved her tim is the
only one who hasn't answered a question
here I'm gonna give this one to you okay
the movie taps into the feeling of being
an outsider and I find that anybody who
feels that way out there can only
benefit from hearing somebody else's
experience if they've gone through
something like that so have you ever
been able to kind of connect to what
some of the characters in this movie are
experiencing and how did you pull
yourself out of it only in the I came
from England to hear on that front and
also doing a fake job so there's that
element but no we've talked about it
we've taught it's that what what we are
our characters who are in feel that
they're in a comfortable in a company in
the comfort zone that they have they
have they are quite liberal and they're
very engaged and they think they feel
that they're doing the right thing they
don't see any any racism within
themselves and that's what we found to
be interesting for us to examine it and
I opposed the outsider question now to
the group because again I think it's an
important conversation to have so is
there any feeling of being able to
relate to any of these characters in any
capacity and maybe if you haven't - just
being steeped in this story for the
shooting period sometimes you can
realise new truths about yourselves
or about somebody else that you might
not have been able to process before I
think everyone feels like an outsider
and anyone who doesn't is an outsider I
feel like it would it be weird like we
all feel like oh my god I wish I wish I
am people understood I wish I wasn't the
only crazy one I wish I wasn't the only
one or the only I think everyone can
relate to that on some level otherwise
they're fakes it's very true
I was wondering a little bit about the
process for you of going from something
like Cloverfield paradox which is a
completely different type of movie here
that a lot of our viewers are very well
aware of - doing something like this
just the importance of being able to do
a big crazy action movie like that but
then also having something like this
that really says something and can make
a big difference in someone's life well
this is actually where I started I mean
I studied theater for my first degree
and I went to film school and these were
the kind of projects I made Cloverfield
was an interesting opportunity to came
my way and but this is kind of my heart
and soul and what I'm truly truly
passionate about so I'm grateful to have
opportunities to do some of the larger
things but I think things like these are
so necessarily important and again just
getting a chance to work with all these
actors it's this is a dream come true
for me
so I'm so thankful for this opportunity
is this anybody's first Sundance just
one did did anyone here give you any
tips or tricks for getting around
Sundance 2019 because this is my first
also and I can tell you that when I got
off the plane I thankfully I'm
surrounded by wonderful people a
Collider who made sure I didn't get
altitude sickness so I'm still standing
no I mean I didn't really tell anyone
that I was coming so early so I really
didn't give them the opportunity to give
me an advice but it's being here has
been amazing I mean this festival is
just so welcoming and so loving it's
definitely not gonna be my last one yeah
I like hearing that
so as a first timer and come
back in the future what tip would you
give somebody else who wants to have a
great Sundance experience I mean book
everything super early I didn't know the
process and so I just kind of came here
willy-nilly um but even just I've met a
lot of strangers who've welcomed me into
their group and just brought me along to
different things yeah so book things
early does anyone get the opportunity to
hang out and see and celebrate other
movies in addition to I mean in some
cases here the multiple movies you're
working on right now nothing nothing I'm
gonna watch me because I have a little
bit more time in the back end of the
festival so there's things I want to
watch what's on the must-see list wolf
hour of course very a very very smart
choice right there Calvin I wanted to
ask you a little bit about the
trajectory of your career because I
remember one of the first times I saw
you on screen was at a Film Festival
where it comes at night premieres and
obviously you really caught my eye on
that so what has the journey been like
for you this is a little bit of a
whirlwind of a festival with some great
performances and again in multiple
movies so how are you feeling right now
and what are you looking forward to in
the future I'm always shocked I don't
know it's been exciting it's been fast
and I just been trying to do as much as
possible and do things that are
interesting to me and I'm enjoying the
process like a special place to be a
great team to be working with so thank
you guys so much for your time today
thank you guys for watching this please
like and share this video and tell
people you know about Luce another thank
you to our good friends at Kia Telluride
for making this happen see you soon with
more Sundance interviews
you